el comité nacional de paro propone que
las campañas políticas sean financiadas
por el estado para evitar intercambios
de favores además piden reformas a los
organismos de control para evitar que
respondan a los intereses del gobierno
de turno y asimismo proponen establecer
que el voto sea obligatorio para que los
políticos no puedan ofrecer pagos a los
ciudadanos para ponerle fin a la
desigualdad proponen que se cree un
subsidio de desempleo que se establezca
el derecho constitucional a la vivienda
así como la gratuidad de un mínimo vital
de agua los campesinos no deberían pagar
peajes en las vías y los estratos más
bajos deberían tener internet gratis
además deberá haber educación gratuita y
de calidad y garantizar el acceso a la
salud para todos los ciudadanos en la
que el cuidado sanitario sea un derecho
y no un negocio como denuncian médicos
en la actualidad en cuanto a seguridad
se exige la eliminación del esmad así
como la creación de espacio de denuncia
de violaciones a los derechos humanos y
agregan que es necesario garantizar la
seguridad de los líderes sociales en
cuanto a sostenibilidad solicitan se
sometan a voto a los proyectos
extractiva y de fracking para que las
propuestas sean financieramente
sostenibles el comité nacional de paro
propone que se establezcan programas de
regreso del dinero al estado como exigir
a los ricos que devuelvan al país el
dinero evadido en impuestos y paguen
mayores tributos así como el recorte de
embajadas y consulados y la exigencia a
los extranjeros en colombia' a
reinvertir el dinero que ganan en el
país